area man really really really hates
cable name's Jon Stewart claims the
upcoming presidential election pushed
his decision to leave the Daily Show
which he has hosted since 1999 after
covering for presidential elections over
his 16-year reign Stewart claims he just
wasn't getting the same level of
satisfaction from hosting as he once did
he explained to the Guardian that quote
these things are cyclical you have
moments of dissatisfaction and then you
come out of it and it's okay
but the cycles become longer and maybe
more entrenched and that's when you
realize okay I'm on the backside of it
now Stewart went on to acknowledge the
daily grind of major news channels like
fox and MSNBC watching these channels
all day is incredibly depressing I live
in a constant state of depression I
think of us as turd miners I put on my
helmet I go in mind turds hopefully I
don't get turd lung disease Trevor Noah
a 30-something South African comedian
will take over the reins of The Daily
Show by early 2016
there you go so John is leaving The
Daily Show Trevor Noah taking over we're
a twirl in the news biz thing here we
talk about the news a lot we tweet about
the news we know what's going on in the
world how how much do you empathize with
that he had to be in this thing
constantly it's it's a sucked isn't it a
soul-sucking thing at some level imagine
being the host of a local show for ten
years with all the same faces in the
audience looking back at you for to do
new material every time you face them
yeah locally you'd go crazy from it
you'd go completely bad we had burnout
from the thing you love yeah I get it I
get it and you know what new people will
come in and take the reins that's the
way it was he was a new person who took
the reins and slowly usurped it all
faith in cable news away to his show
rather than there you've done local news
and The Young Turks and plenty other TV
stuff how much of just having to know
about this stuff and still perform and
be out there and say what you think like
that it just takes a certain toll on you
let me say one thing first
my mother a real progressive woman was
the only person I've ever heard used the
word usurp except in regard to like 19th
century European powers right so uh I
you know I don't think there's any
there's no you
this is without conspiracy theory that
read incredibly true you'd do something
almost anything that long that requires
that much investment unless it changes
and as Rick said it doesn't really
change it's the same kind of thing
you've got to sort of make change out of
what is the same kind of story again and
again you know right it was Rick
Santorum in 2012 and now it's Ted Cruz
but they're saying the same inspirited
hideous things and yes so I think it's a
it's it's legitimate and I don't buy an
idea that he they picked Trevor Noah so
he'd fail so Stuart would look you know
that's all Twitter but why does John
Stuart need to be more validated like it
doesn't matter of traffic John Stuart
he's good you know not Craig Kilborn
John Stuart is the godfather of that
show Jon Stewart made that show what
else and when you make a movie that's
pretty good and you you know and you
enjoy it and it was kind of an important
movie like you know he could say I don't
really know am I thinking about that
right now but he wasn't I guarantee you
he wants to direct some more movies he
was he was pretty good at it and
directors get better as they go along
yeah I would imagine that's exactly what
he wants to do to your point about how
the show turned I interned at the Daily
Show in 1999 when Craig Kilborn had just
left and Comedy Central was barely a
network at that time I mean not only did
they build this show into an institution
but they built the entire network how
important you think is is satire in the
political scheme of things you know our
friend Jimmy Dore always says this thing
about how Chuck Todd admitted on Meet
the Press that if he ever asks a hard
question
the guest will never come back so we
need satire more than ever right to call
out the [ __ ] because the media is
never going to do it right that's it
Bill Maher still holding down the fort
you're holding down the fort new voices
will rise up and fill in the need the
the demand for it is now going to create
its own March so that's it that's a
beautiful thing right right yeah that's
a it's a yeah it's totally beautiful
thing it's it's it's but you know it's
it's it's vitally important and you know
he this creating that it was amazing is
he is that idea that is too easily
dismissed but that show is more
trustworthy than almost any other show
on on cable loose I'm worried for Trevor
Noah just because anybody stepping in to
that kind of expectation it's tough I
mean that's a that's a tough thing to do
even if you're great at it I mean you
know I the TCM festival or any of you
George Lazenby who is a interesting guy
a crazy guy and not a little
misogynistic and but but taking over for
Sean Connery yeah was impossible and
that movie on Her Majesty's Secret
Service which was it is great now great
it's a great bond it might be my
favorite Bond it's one of the top three
but it was an impossible task to replace
Sean Connery and it might be an
impossible task to replace Jon Stewart
on The Daily Show yeah a Trevor Noah
might be the guy who was like who was
the guy in between Jon Stewart and and
whoever this next guy is who blows I
hope not I hope he perhaps Dave Rubin
perhaps Dave Rubin is dead just to be
clear so is there a different Dave Rubin
are you talking about you being a room
in the casting director actually to that
point I did text my manager the day that
John said he was stepping down and I
said can I get on a list or an audition
or something he wrote back lol so I
don't think we're gonna be working
together anymore anyway what do you
think is John gonna go up and do great
things and is Trevor know we're gonna be
alright as the Daily Show host let us
know in the comments right now